big match either way and he'll be ready
there we go E4 to start this one off
Simon your thoughts on the body language
there
well back to the expert as always and
they're both quite cagey their hands are
hiding something that may be hiding
their preparation but you see that
Wesley's hand is a little bit lovey and
there you go the first surprise Wesley
head in his hands a little laugh he's
clearly shocked there and it's one nil
with a little smile as well let's talk
about why let's talk about why if anyone
missed Notre back's demolishing of
lebanaroni and shame on you you should
check it out but he played a dubious
opening that notabeck himself said
remember guys that he's like look that
opening is objectively lost for white no
meaning what he did but he crushed
aronian now he's playing another opening
that is objectively dubious we weren't
wrong in terms of how we evaluated it
but it's full of traps and full of
tricks and Wesley's like you saw the
reaction he's like oh crap here we go
like what is this kid got in store with
some sort of magical preparation
we've talked about the English opening
the Dutch defense the French this is the
Portuguese opening and you nearly never
hear about it yeah so rare it hits the
now this bishop look I love that he's
he's laughing he can't believe this move
it's usually played on the third move
but this time on the second move is this
psychological warfare by not the back I
mean this is like the drunken rule Lopez
isn't it it's like you've played it in
one move
I've got my knight out yeah what have I
done it's the kind of thing you know 10
point rule Lopez how many times have you
played the drunken Roy Lopez um I've
never played for all Lopez actually
which is weird but I've done the other
thing very well over the course of My
Life
um but yeah it's it's a stranger because
it's basically saying to Black okay
attack me I mean again if if a pupil I
don't really teach anymore but if a
pupil of mine had played this move I'd
be like you can't play mood Riders he's
laughing wow you can't keep it together
dude like I'm surprised and Wesley also
I think can see him on camera because
Wesley's like oh like you're laughing
I'm laughing but Wesley's also burning
his clock right now and it's going to be
pretty funny Westie develops tonight
takes out the king side night and we
have a royal Lopez a Spanish but
Wesley's burned two minutes on the clock
it's very weird because yeah I mean I
you're asking black to attack your
Bishop aren't you I mean like you move a
piece into your opponent's half of the
board the first thing generally your
opponent does is kick that piece away
but this time I I don't know David the
Portuguese variation I mean it just
looks weird to me but I love it and I
love the way that he's got Wesley
thinking on move too how often do you
get Wesley thinking on mood two a few
moments later not a bag does just resign
and with that win vessel takes the lead